[Musik]
ich mache Schupfnudeln Maxim
an ja
Liebe Sally wir möchten Dich gerne in
unser Kenwood Headquarter in haven't
einladen
wir freuen uns auf gemeinsame Tage mit
dir oh die Ponys voll schwer auf eine
kulinarische Reise
Großbritannien spannende food Trends
[Musik]
wir gehen nach England du schon ich
nicht warum will ich kein Visum für
England bekommen
wir gehen nach England oh mein Gott
Shortbread schwarzer Tee den nehme ich
mit
wir fliegen nach London und ich nehme
euch mit
boah ich freue mich so
Sally heißt John steht hier auf dem
Flugticket vielleicht wussten die auch
schon dass du kein Visum kriegst
versteht nämlich viel Spaß in heaven
danke
und ich nehme jetzt Euch mit auf die
Reise nach England und wir besuchen
Kenwood in Haven und gehen noch ein
bisschen nach London würde ich mal sagen
oder
kommt mit
[Musik]
ich glaube ja so dass England Wetter
wenn nichts für mich denn in Waghäusel
scheint immer die Sonne
[Musik]
das ist schön
wir sind jetzt hier am boro-market das
ist einer der ältesten foodmärkte hier
in London und die Geschichte geht sogar
bis ins 13 jahrhundert zurück da gehen
wir jetzt mal rein und entdecken mal was
hier alles Leckeres gibt
[Musik]
jetzt probieren wir mal den berühmten
naughty Brownie von Oliviers Bakery
das very naughty
[Musik]
boah da hast du richtig Interesse wie
bei Murat in der Türkei nur glaube ich
dass das hier einfach ist ein Trüffel zu
kommen als Murat in der Türkei
die zweimal schon ziemlich Abenteuer
erlebt
[Musik]
mach die Hunde weg wir sind hier in
Denizli und zwar mit dem Leben zusammen
und mit dem Günni auf jeden Fall lebend
und wir wir gehen jetzt los auf die
trüffeljagd
lich gemerkt Steckdose bei Dir rein
Mensch
[Musik]
ich liebe Käse ich liebe richtig so
aromatischen starken würzigen Käse
[Musik]
türkisch die Light wir schauen jetzt mal
okay
[Musik]
1 2 3
wir fahren ja später noch zwei Stunden
nach heavent mit dem Auto deswegen packe
ich mir jetzt einfach mal
Zutaten zum Backen bei Kenwood und aber
auch Snacks für die Fahrt damit man
nicht verhungern im Auto
[Musik]
die sind Rohne
komm mal lieber zum schokoladenstand
drauf
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die hängt da noch darf ich nicht davor
ekeln
drauf
da Sascha da macht noch Toppings drauf
hier tschüss
war gar nicht so schlecht
die sehen halt so
wie bei Pringles
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
man darf sich halt keine Gedanken drüber
machen dass
diese Muschel so eine seltsame
Konsistenz hat denn im Mund wird es dann
immer mehr
das dann schon ein bisschen komisch aber
geschmacklich was kommt okay
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt den perfekten Stand für
Ananas
nicht alkoholisches deswegen ist für
dich okay
[Musik]
ich bin richtig stolz auf meine Baum
thank you
in dem Wasser
[Musik]
also ich finde wenn man schon auf dem
borrormarket ist dann muss man auf jeden
Fall hungrig herkommen hat natürlich den
Nachteil mal probiert alles und man
kauft auch alles aber ist auch gut so
denn ich finde nur so entdeckt man ja
auch Neues von Sandwich
und WoW
that
sehr gut
obwohl Kümmel drin ist
[Musik]
morgen gehen wir ins Headquarter von
Kenwood und so viel warte dort auf uns
und wird mit uns was kochen und packen
da bin ich schon ein bisschen aufgeregt
und gespannt drauf was uns zeigen wird
ich hoffe es sind traditionelle
britische Gerichte und ich kaufe jetzt
einfach ein bisschen Obst und Gemüse
nimm das mit und dann werden wir einfach
schauen was da draußen
[Musik]
das war es jetzt habe ich hier einiges
gekauft und wir haben auch einiges
probiert morgen geht es direkt ins
Headquarter von Kenwood und da bin ich
mal gespannt drauf wenn ich da so alles
kennenlerne und vor allem was wir
zubereiten werden
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt hier gerade in heavent im
Headquarter von Kenwood und das war
richtig gerade sitze ist wirklich
original der Wagen mit dem damals
kennethood also der Erfinder der Kenwood
durch die Städte zog und seine Maschine
vorgeführt hat also so wie ich es jetzt
heute auf Youtube mache und euch einfach
Rezepte demonstriere und zeige wie toll
das Kochen und Backen ist hat erst
damals in diesem Wagen gemacht um aber
seine Maschine vorzufüllen und zu zeigen
wie funktional die Maschine ist und ich
würde sagen wir gehen jetzt mal
gemeinsam rein lernen das gesamte
Kenwood Team kennen und schauen was uns
erwartet ich glaube nur der kenne das
war ein bisschen kleiner als ich also
jetzt glaube ich Probleme damit den
Wagen zu fahren
[Musik]
wir werden alle Maschinen getestet
Langzeit Kurzzeit und es wird wirklich
alles also die Temperatur der Maschine
des Motors wie viel Ausdauer sie hat wie
lange sie lebt und was ich ganz toll
finde es werden zum Beispiel einmalig
dann Teige hergestellt wie zum Beispiel
so ein Pizzateig damit gemessen wie viel
Energie da reingesteckt werden muss um
eben diese Zutaten miteinander zu
kombinieren und daraufhin wird dann
etwas synthetisches hergestellt damit
man eben keine Lebensmittel verschwendet
und dann auch zum Beispiel so einen Teig
einfach 24 Stunden 4 Wochen 8 Wochen
einfach am Stück testen kann und dann
eben diese Materialien hat ohne
Lebensmittelverschwendung zu vertreiben
also die hier laufen jetzt schon über 50
Stunden am Stück und dann hören sie
immer mal wieder auf dann starten wir
wieder hören wir da auf und das soll er
quasi so den zu Hause gebraucht über den
Jahre simulieren
es sind
ich würde einfach so just for fun alle
Zutaten pink einfärben einfach damit
hübsch aussieht oder Rainbow da guck mal
so rein und sieht auch
einfach so
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eigentlich wie bei uns daheim wenn wir
auch 3D Drucker bei uns und das heißt
wir haben zum Beispiel irgendwo ein
Problem in der Küche dann gehe ich zum
Emre er zeichnet das dann das Produkt
einfach 3D ist ja auch industrial
designer dann drucken wir das ganze über
den 3D Drucker kannst direkt
ausprobieren und wenn es dann gut ist
können wir es direkt produzieren
deswegen geht ihr immer alles so schnell
und bei Kenwood ist das auch so die
haben auch eine 3D Drucker können alles
ausprobieren direkt und haben dann
gleich die Ergebnisse ist auch gut weil
man eben viel Zeit und Geld und vor
allem viel Energie spart
[Musik]
Selbstschussanlage ich stand da gerade
und war so ein bisschen so
aber die stellen da war anscheinend
wirklich die Maschinen hin und feuern da
einfach alles drauf die ganze Elektrik
und gucken halt was die Maschine alles
ab kann und vor allem ob dann noch was
zurückgeht weil es wäre ja echt schlecht
wenn da
strommäßig was andere Verbraucher
sozusagen rausgeht wenn sie z.B gerade
an der Maschine dran sind deswegen wird
hier alles auf wie heißt das auf Herz
und Nieren getestet
[Musik]
hier sind wir gerade in der
Versuchsküche und da werden die Maschine
natürlich auch getestet zum Beispiel
verschiedene Programme wie es Brunch
cake ist bei uns in Deutschland einfach
der Rührkuchen und in England bezeichnen
sie damit den All-in-One Tag das heißt
alle Zutaten kommen in die Rührschüssel
und dann muss dieses Programm eben
ablaufen eine Minute zum Beispiel bei
Stufe 1 da ist dann erstmal eine
niedriger Stufe dann geht es etwas höher
und kommt dann wieder etwas runter mit
der Stufe damit am Anfang die Zutaten
eben nicht rausspritzen sondern erstmal
vermengt werden dann schau mich gerührt
werden und dann geht's wieder dem Ende
zu und hier testet war das ganze dann
auch gerne mit Lebensmittelfarbe wenn
man dann eben auch sieht dass die
Zutaten alle homogen verrührt werden und
das wird man eben nicht sehen wenn man
jetzt nur Eier und Butter und Zucker
verwendet weil da eben die Zutaten die
selber Farbe haben und so sieht man ganz
genau alles schön hellblau das heißt für
mich alles ist gut
jetzt bin ich hier in der Versuchsküche
bei Kenwood und treffe heute Sophie
sie ist die Expertin wenn es um die
Kenwood COOKING CHEF geht und auch die
Experten wenn es ums Rezepte entwickeln
geht und heute zeigt sie mir ein paar
richtig traditionelle britische Gerichte
wenn ich jetzt mal gespannt drauf
[Musik]
ich freue mich schon
um unser Cornish Pest wie herzustellen
brauchen wir einen Teig dann herzhaften
Mürbeteig besteht einfach aus Mehl Ei
Salz und etwas Butter und zwar ist das
eine Fleischpastete und früher hat man
die einfach auf der Hand mitgenommen und
Sophie hat erzählt dass früher die
Kruste auch gar nicht mitgegessen wurde
sondern nur das Innere der Pastete und
heutzutage ist man natürlich auch das
Äußere der Pastete mit also auch
die Kruste und zwar ist das eine ein
Rezept was sehr herzhaft ist sehr
sättigen sehr wohltuend das hat man
gerne morgens gegessen damit man eben
viel Energie für den Tag hat also die
Zutaten kommen jetzt alle ganz ruhig in
den Teig und im Ofen werden sie dann
sozusagen dampfgarten
[Musik]
perfect
das ist jetzt hier schon die Tat einfach
vorbereitet hat Rezepte findet ihr auch
schon auf meinem Kanal und auch Lemon
Curd das haben wir auch schon hier
vorbereitet jetzt gibt's die
baiser-schicht für obendrauf und die
baiserschicht wird einfach erwärmt und
da benutzen wir gleich das Programm ich
zeige euch das auch gleich und Eiweiß
ist schon drin Salz ist auch schon da
zuckerwiegen wir kurz rein
[Musik]
normalerweise wird man jetzt so vorgehen
dass man eiweiß mit Zucker und Salz über
dem warmen kochenden Wasserbad erhitzt
auf dem Herd und ständig rühren muss wir
benutzen jetzt hier die Kenwood COOKING
CHEF und werden jetzt hier Eiweiß
erhitzen und normalerweise 10 Minuten
über dem kochenden Wasserbad da weiß man
auch ganz genau das Eiweiß ist genug
erhitzt und später wird es runtergekühlt
hier habe ich jetzt das Programm und
kannst einstellen und hier brauche ich
dann auch keine 10 Minuten denn das
ganze wird er erwärmt und dann wenn es
die 85 Grad erreicht hat dann zählt die
Uhr runter das heißt man kann von 2
Minuten einfach ein bisschen höher noch
gehen weil man zum Beispiel hier jetzt
eine große Menge Eiweiß hat bei einer
kleinen Menge Eiweiß reicht sogar so ein
bisschen Programm schon vorgegeben ist
[Musik]
ja da bleibt halt mehr Zeit zum
Dekorieren ne statt über dem Herd jetzt
Eiweiß aufzuschlagen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wir haben jetzt hier noch
heruntergekühlt ein paar Minuten aber
ich meine perfekter kann der Baisermasse
einfach nicht sein ja
glänzend schön steif geschlagen
that's perfect
and
children don't like the specialer
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
geschafft und ich habe die Küche auch
nicht verbrannt okay perfekt
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir fertig mit unserem
leckeren Essen wir haben Hauptspeisen
wir haben Nachtisch ich glaube wir haben
echt genug Essen für alle Frauen Männer
alle dürfen kommen jetzt erstmal alle
gemeinsam mit dem kenwood-team und ich
würde sagen die Rezeptideen die nämlich
auf jeden Fall mit für euch nach Hause
nach Waghäusel da sehen wir uns dann
wieder ja war richtig schön okay
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir alle satt und glücklich
thank you for the good food I will I
really enjoyed cooking in baking with
you and thank you also for the great
conversations Cover ist zum Beispiel
verantwortlich für den ganzen Content
der online geht auch in der App was ihr
eben alles dort finden könnt was so
Rezepte Kenwood COOKING CHEF und die App
angeht deswegen war es jetzt richtig
schön für mich mit beiden hier gemeinsam
zu kochen und zu backen mich
auszutauschen auch über Rezepte z.B oder
auch was man noch alles hochladen könnte
vielleicht wisst ihr ja auch also jemand
der vielleicht schon eine Kennwort hat
kennt vielleicht auch schon den Kenwood
klappt da gibt's nämlich auch Rezepte
aus der Community aber es gibt eben auch
Rezepte von Kenwood direkt die eben hier
in der Versuchsküche entstehen und dann
quasi sind und hochgeladen werden und da
wollen wir natürlich in Zukunft auch
einfach viel mehr machen so wir gehen
jetzt nach draußen denn ich habe noch
eine Überraschung für euch und ihr
werdet euch gleich richtig umhauen
und zwar seht ihr den Wagen hier hinter
mir und zwar wird der Magen von der
Maschine da vorne nämlich gezogen sie
haben dort an der Rührschüssel einfach
was ausgeschnitten da hängt jetzt eine
Schnur dran der Wagen ist hier hinten
dran der ist aus also kein Motor läuft
einfach nur der Ganges raus und gleich
werden wir sehen ob die Maschine es
schafft den Wagen von hier nach dort zu
sehen bin schon ziemlich gespannt drauf
weil ich finde so eine Küchenmaschine da
denkt man halt ja so ein bisschen Kochen
bisschen Backen bisschen Teig kneten
oder bisschen rühren aber es hat doch
ein bisschen mehr als nur eine
Küchenmaschine und ich glaube daran
sehen wir gleich wie stark und wie viel
Kraft Energie und vor allem wie viel
Ingenieurwissen da einfach in so einer
Maschine steckt ich gehe jetzt mal rein
[Musik]
das ist so cool ich meine eigentlich ist
es einfach nur eine Küchenmaschine die
hat hier gerade einen Wagen gezogen
jetzt wird auch einiges klar warum so
gut so gut Hefeteige nudelteige und
alles andere knetet oder das hat man
echt noch nicht gesehen cool thank you
das macht den halt Spaß ja den Jungs aus
dem Ingenieurbüro da haben Sie Spaß dran
[Musik]
guckt mal aus hier entdeckt habe
nimm wenig Kenwood sag's euch das war
was gewesen für meinen Puppenhaus dass
ich nie hatte aber wenn ich eins gehabt
hätte dann wäre es sowas gewesen
voll süß
wieder schön hier
[Musik]
richtig süß ich habe für Samira und Ella
eine kleine Kenwood bekommen damit sie
zu Hause auch ein bisschen rühren können
voll süß
[Musik]
ja ein krah-haken der ist eingraviert da
steht Sally drauf
[Musik]
das ist richtig süß denke ich auch mal
wollte ich süße Idee da könnt ihr auch
wenn ihr eine Küchenmaschine zum
Beispiel verschenkt könnt ihr Autos für
Element vorher gravieren lassen mit dem
Namen eurer eures liebsten
richtig schön
[Musik]
okay
jetzt sind wir wieder zurück in
Waghäusel und ich finde es war eine
bezaubernde Reise nach England ich habe
viel viel Neues gesehen viel entdeckt
und viele tolle Menschen kennengelernt
die im Unternehmen bei Kenwood arbeiten
und natürlich sollt ihr auch was davon
haben denn ich habe ja eine Kenwood für
euch mitgeschmuggelt sozusagen diese
Kenwood COOKING CHEF in schwarz gehört
euch ihr könnt hier nämlich jetzt beim
Gewinnspiel mitmachen und was ich noch
brandneu mit dazu bekommen habe ist der
passieraufsatz der passier Aufsatz damit
könnt ihr wirklich alles mögliche machen
was ich normalerweise dann immer mit der
flotten Lotte oder mit einem Sieb
einfach mache Marmeladen gelesen ihr
könnt auch Pudding durch passieren wenn
ihr zum Beispiel eine Buttercreme aus
Pudding macht also da passiert ist auch
wirklich super toll und variationsreich
und einsetzbar in der kompletten Küche
ihr könnt auch Ketchup kochen und das
verwenden also da habt ihr wirklich ganz
viel Spaß und der ist jetzt ganz neu bei
Kenwood wird auch demnächst bei mir in
der Küche zum Einsatz kommen und ihr
könnt jetzt gerne einfach dieses Video
kommentieren und zum Beispiel schreiben
was wäre denn das erste Rezept das erste
Gericht was ihr zubereiten würdet wenn
ihr diese Kenwood gewinnt schreibt es
mir ganz gerne in die Kommentare
schreibt mir auch gerne wie euch das
Video gefallen hat und ich lege euch
dann noch also einmal gibt es dieses Set
zu gewinnen und ich lege euch dann noch
meinen aktuellstes Kochbuch dazu kochen
für jeden Anlass da gibt es auch viele
Rezepte Ideen und viel Inspiration für
euch zum Kochen ein paar Desserts sind
auch mit dabei und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel Freude damit ich wünsche euch ganz
viel Glück und einer von euch wird
dieses schöne wundervolle Set gewinnen
bei der Kenwood ist natürlich einfach
die Grundausstattung mit dabei also alle
rührelemente Hitzeschutz
spritzdeckel abspritzschutz zum Abdecken
alles Mögliche was eben hier zur
Maschine dazu gehört also ich bin schon
gespannt auf eure Kommentare bis zum
nächsten Mal
[Gelächter]
dieser Wind
ich bin überfordert
[Gelächter]
[Musik]